um okay let's try this the Kings Indian
all right whoa now okay what do you do
when you see something that's a bit
atypical huh what do you do all rights
looking for like a quick kill I castle
Bishop here throwing my eh pond down my
throat what are the drawbacks of Queen
here let's do this so I might now
encounter some issues with castling if
the bishop is maintained on this
diagonal I couldn't castle but since
it's backing up here how can i maybe
exploit this Queen's position on c1 I
think I'd like to have the C file open
up so that when my rook plays here
there's maybe some issue maybe I could
force that Queen to have to make an
additional move I think this now turns
out to backfire the Queen's position but
it might have been a different story
again if the bishop were to stay on this
diagonal I couldn't castle as easily and
I don't see a reason to release this
tension the center just yet there is no
pawn push and well now maybe black is
getting ready if it takes instead of
seed through I always had check and then
picking it right off on the next turn
but now if I just played e5 takes white
might be able to just hang on to it so
maybe I should now go with the capture
or I guess Queen B 6 is enough an
alternative maybe I like Queen B 6 yeah
i'm gonna go with Queen B 6 and then and
then this d5 move and then get my bishop
out to maybe f5 I don't see any hurry in
this type of position with castling I'm
really wanting to I think to get my rook
to see a really soon I want to make this
Queen flinch I want to see what she's
going to do
so I wanted to declare her intentions I
don't know if I really want to push g5 i
do want to play d5 right now though i
don't want this night coming to see for
to hit my queen so lets rule that out
right away but now there's an issue on
this square so i think now i don't i
don't want to close the sea follow-up or
maybe I maybe I do huh I was really a
lot of my attention early on was to have
this C file open up but maybe I could
get my beep on rolling mmm no now I want
I want to get my rook opposite the Queen
I believe it should be the epon that
takes however there couldn't maybe be
some okay I'm not afraid of that because
now I have a two-to-one majority in the
center i could play this move with tempo
should i do it right now I don't see a
reason to not do it right now
oh hang on got a little nervous there a
little nervous guy i mean my knights
protected I was uh had a little gasp
right there cuz i was thinkin that the
night could jump in to be five and come
here with check but I could castle just
in time and if the night plays here I
could just could always move my bishop
and I think the night runs the risk of
getting trapped if it gets too d three
it's not really hitting anything if it
can't make a capture on c8 so I think
the quick assessment here I think a
computer would be saying that I Black's
tans better I have more space I have a
better center there's no I'm not lagging
in development if Knight takes Knight
how should I recapture oh okay I don't
have a choice really with that if Knight
takes Knight I don't know why there was
a need to give up that dark square
Bishop okay the Knights ready to come
here but I castle just in time is this
the idea upon push this can't be correct
how could I be so confident how could I
be so confident about that this can't be
the correct idea if this night can't
make use of d6 successfully this night
is then going to be out of play on a 3
and this night on b3 I think well at
least in my mind I'm already viewing
this night on b3 is being out of play
seeing how this pun is on a half of a
file i think i do well to just place the
bishop right here there's not really
going to be a better square i don't
think i could kick this night away right
away let's do it so he's got to go to a
three and now next up i think i throw my
rook opposite the Queen something I've
been wanting to do something I've been
talking about for quite a bit I do have
the bishop pair so
any additional generally speaking any
additional pond exchanges are going to
be benefiting me so let's throw another
rook still opposite the Queen and this
is the break maybe I should be trying to
get in and I think it's the one that I
can get in however as soon as this pawn
makes a capture the Queen can maybe be
picking off h6 so I am considering King
g7 I don't know if pushing here maybe
just it's best to tuck the king in right
here in some sense a little a little bit
closer to the center i'm also looking at
just d4 right away with takes takes I'm
kind of liking this but maybe another
way to view this is that there's
absolutely no rush I think this is a
pawn break that I can get in no matter
what unless this night plays here I
think I could slow play this i'm pretty
sure they're i don't think there's any
rush I'm I'm retaining my center and i'm
looking to induce some weakness h3 maybe
I could get a dark square battery ok I
think that this is going to be very
annoying okay he's a giant thorn without
a doubt I'm on this rook I don't know
that white should have allowed that that
I don't think that that should have been
allowed ok I'm going to rear out my
night and I'm doing this in my queen
could recapture the bishop i'm looking
to now it take on h2 this is my plan i'm
going to keep the center right here
these nights unfortunately don't have
support points come over here this is
going to be very dangerous there might
already be something involved with rook
takes I could push here I'm not going to
do that though wait palm push what's my
clock okay hang on
I could do Brooke here and then just
double up but I think I want to get my
night into this f 3 square I think I
should just move fast 40 seconds I think
I can give up the two rooks and get the
Queen and return in my queen and night
alone should be able to do some damage
go with that and now actually okay it's
not even that so the king is just trying
to run away but I don't think it's going
to be able to run away this is too
difficult i'm controlling way too many
squares i believe the queen turns out to
be trapped now yeah she's she's running
out of squares where is that knockout
could have also played pong up the Queen
could run away in this direction but
seeing that there's got to be some night
check followed by a queen f5 I think
this is now working it should be working
night check so the King can't play here
and if pawn takes clean here Queen here
is also another possibility Queen h3
basically just a clearance that night
move was and it came with check there is
Queen f2 and that's going to be game all
right good game Colossus let's back up
and let me flip the board and see if we
could take a thing or two away from this
so I think if you're really to make
again if you're going to make this an
inconvenience for me maybe consider
Bishop f4 it's true that I could be I
could still play g5 but ok it's a bit
more weakening to my king side f5 is
really the one that's that pops right
out in my mind if I'm doing g5 I'm
thinking already if I lose my light
square Bishop and a white knight gets
there or your night gets there I'm
going to be suffering so I really didn't
want to have to do g5 and that's kind of
why ended up never doing g5 in this game
so maybe Bishop f4 is going to be a bit
better and I think because of maybe the
bishops decision in okay I mean this is
a very solid set up something that I
think a structure that I've played
played with many times more times than
any other structure in the game is this
one right here it's a little pond
triangle controlling dark squares
getting that dark square Bishop outside
but okay you put a question this pun I
think this is the big turning point
however I know that there was a there's
going to be a difference between bishop
h4 and Bishop f4 when I put a question
to the bishop with age 6 but this right
here is it an even bigger turning point
and that is how the recapture I think
you have to go with the pond and I like
I like going with their look there's
four different pieces that could capture
both nights both ponds how do I know it
should be this one well if you take with
the sea pond if you follow the rule of
taking towards the center I don't like
that this C file is wide open already
just the bishop out rook c8 this is
going to be a problem Bishop f5 in
particular and you know just the idea of
a night move to be for focusing on c2
with check or maybe even Queen checks
you know it opens up there's two ways to
actually view at taking with the seep on
a d4 opens up this diagonal it opens up
this file taking with both either night
is going to allow a 2-1 majority in
favor of me as was the case in the game
taking with the epon well you don't have
those issues on the C file and you could
follow up with castle and eventually get
your book on e one half open file I
think that's really the way to go I'm
pretty sure if there was a computer
evaluation it would kind of be fluctuate
it would change at this at this moment
right here taking with the night
instead of the e pond I think it would
be recommending the eponymous ertan of
course but anyhow that's that's the big
turning point you gave up the bishop i'm
not sure what the intention was exactly
what that but there's no compensation
now I have the bishop pair I have a good
Center there's no you know have a lead
and development type of thing or can
capitalize on a hole in my position
there really isn't anything to really
take advantage of my I guess my last
recommendation is to not really allow
this giant thorn with age three maybe
you should be playing first h3 and then
go with this Bishop g4 idea but now it's
a problem with this pond capture then
this week he's a weak link he's your
isolated pond I've already bumped up my
king and I'm ready to roll on that age
file okay good game nicolaas let me
close out